before we say goodbye let's play a quick  round of truth or dare  and today we have beth hi beth hi it's  drew i'm so excited to do this with you  this is so exciting thank you for having  me well what's it gonna be truth or dare  it is a dare okay  okay i'm willing to do anything anything  at all yes all right so i do a little  bit of working out i don't do a lot okay  don't have the best upper body strength  so i thought maybe we can share this  experience together i love it let's do  push-ups okay what do you think let's  try it now do you want to do lady  push-ups or do you want to do the actual  push-ups i'll probably go for lady  push-ups all right do you want to do it  together let's do it together cool okay  all right  [Music]  [Music]  feeling it yes  [Music]  do you want to keep going you had enough  [Music]  [Music]  oh  thank you bad  [Music]